So with that context in mind, let's now jump into creating a core UMG widget and talk about
creating a HUD and a reusable widget.
So we'll jump into an engine now.
And when we're in engine, we'll start by creating a new HUD widget.
So I've got a HMI folder here.
I'll just right click and go to new folder and I'll type blueprints here because we'll
be making a few different blueprints today.
I'm going to right click and I'll go to user interface and then we'll go to widget blueprint
at the bottom here.
I use a widget is fine.
So we'll just click that and we'll type HUD underscore UMG today.
And then we'll just hit enter to open it up.
And what I like to do is I like to just pin this next to the map here so it's a bit easier
to toggle between the two.
So now that we've created a new widget, we want to check the fill screen at the top right
of the viewport here.
So we've got fill screen here and we can set a desired screen size.
And so we'll do desired on screen.
If you'd like to set a specific screen size there, we have these options.
We can also just do a custom on screen as well.
So whichever kind of aspects you want to work with, I'm just going to use 1920, 1080,
which is going to be my aspect on the PC, but you can set the real estate to whatever
you would like it to be there.
And then on the top left hand side, we just need a canvas panel, which we will drag down
into here and so that we have our canvas panel now part of our hierarchy in the bottom left
hand side here.
So we've got our basic layout.
We will jump into creating a new blueprint now so that we can actually add this widget
to some kind of class.
So I'm just going to compile and save.
Again, we're just building the foundations right now of our functionality.
So I'm back in my content browser.
I'm going to go to new blueprint class by right clicking and this time we will select
player controller.
And this is just going to be a display controller.
And what we were talking about in the PowerPoint just a few minutes ago is that we need some
kind of controller that can interact with the scene.
As you recall, controllers can take input and consume input commands.
So that's why we've created a controller right now.
So I'm going to hit enter to open it up again.
Alternatively, you can just double click this, but when it's already selected, you can just
hit enter to open.
I'm just going to save it just to make sure we have the save preferences.
And I'll go to the event graph in the top middle here.
So when we go to the event graph, we can delete the tick if you'd like it like to delete that.
Again, it doesn't really have functionality, it just cleans it up a bit.
And so we'll go from the event begin play, and we'll create a widget.
So create widget.
So you just draw, drag off the the white execution pin and go to create widget.
And we'll have something like that.
And then we just want to find the hood that we just created.
So we called it hood underscore UMG.
So we'll add that there.
And then we want to promote this to a variable.
So we'll drag off the blue pin and say promotes a variable.
And we'll call this hood underscore UMG reference, something like this.
It doesn't matter what the specific name is, as long as it's consistent with your naming
convention and that you remember what that name is for use later on.
And then the last thing we want to do, we've got the controller, we've created our hood
widget, now we just need to add it to the screen.
So to do that, we say add to viewport.
So we'll just click add to viewport.
And as we now add functionality to this widget, it will get added to the viewport as long
as we have our game mode set correctly, which we will do in the coming time here.
So let's create our first bit of functionality to make sure we can see our UMG display and
just make sure everything's working correctly.
So I'm going to go back into the hood UMG now.
I'm going to find a vertical box.
So I'll go to vertical box.
I'm going to drag and drop that down into here.
And so you'll see a new box has been added and we can position this wherever we would
like.
We can change the positioning.
It doesn't really matter too much for these purposes, but I'll just drag it out so you
can see that happening.
And maybe I'll make it a little bit bigger.
And we want to add a text box.
So we'll just display some kind of text on the screen.
So I'll get the text box and drag and drop that down to the vertical box as well.
And then I will also add a name slot underneath that.
There we go.
So the text is just a text block there.
And the name slot comes in at 180 by default.
I'm just going to rename that at the top here.
Just name slot and then I'll compile and save.
And then we can jump into our graph, which is on the top right here to start adding some
kind of functionality.
So we'll go to the graph.
And we've got the event pre construct, which is what we want to use at the moment.
So we want a few variables on the left hand side to add before we get into any kind of
functionality.
So we want to actually find our text block and make sure that our text block is editable.
So let's go back into our designer.
Let's get this text block here, select the text block, and then just say is variable.
We can take that up there, compile and save.
And we'll go back into our graph.
And you can now see that that text block is there.
So we can also rename that.
You don't need to do this, but I just want to make sure that the text block just nice
clean naming conventions, compile and save, go back there.
And so everything looks a little bit more organized.
And then we just want to create a new variable as well.
Something along the lines of display text.
And we'll create a named variable from this.
So we'll change it from Boolean to will it be a text?
I believe it might be a text variable.
So we'll just compile and save that.
And then we'll drag out the display text.
I'm going to hold down control on my keyboard and drag out alternatively, you can just left
mouse drag out.
But then it'll say do you want to get or set the variable by holding down control, you
will get the variable.
And by holding down alt, you will set the variable.
So that's just a little shortcut in case you want to use that there.
I'll compile and save.
And then we want to set the text.
So I'm just going to move these two events, we don't really need them at the moment.
I'm going to grab the text block.
So I'm going to hold down control again and drag that out.
And I'll drag off the blue pin of the text block and just say set text.
So select set text there.
And then we'll have the text there.
And that'll be plugged in like that.
So we're under pre construct, we've got some display text, and you want the text block
to set the text.
Now it's not going to set any text because we don't have any default information.
So we'll just type test there, compile and save.
And so that's our basic setup for making sure we have editable content.
And the last thing we want to do is just make sure that variable is public, so that that
is instance editable.
And then we'll compile and save.
And then before we move on, let's just make sure we can display the content on our screen.
So we'll go to the display map and we need to create a new game mode.
So we'll right click and go to blueprint class.
And we'll select game mode base from here.
And we'll just call that display game mode.
And then open that up.
And we just want to make sure the player controller is assigned correctly.
So the player controller is our display controller.
And we'll compile and save that.
We'll go to our default map, we'll make sure on the world settings, if you don't have world
settings open, you can make sure that the windows open on world settings, and just make
sure that display game mode is set there.
And then we'll save all.
I'm going to full screen my window by pressing F11 and go and hit alt and P on the keyboard.
And you'll see that our test is now visible on the top left hand side there.
So you'll throughout this process, we've kind of created a new game mode that will display,
well, use some kind of controller that takes input in the controller.
We've added the UMG to the screen via this blueprint scripting here.
And then the controller says load this HUD and add it to the screen.
And the HUD that we've created, which we can find by searching here is this UMG HUD.
And the UMG HUD basically says, get some text and display text.
So whatever's in this variable right now, if I change this to hello, and compile and
save, then if I full screen and press alt P on the keyboard, you can see hello there.
So we've got some really nice basic functionality of a UMG setup.
We know that everything's working correctly before we move on.
So let's jump into the next section.
Next we'll create a right panel widget using a sub menu, which will house a lot of interactive
functionality that we can add to our scene.
So let's jump into the editor again.
And so we're back in editor now, we've got our HUD UMG class open.
Now that we know this is working, I'm going to change custom back to fill screen, because
that's going to be the desired behavior we want as we start adding more panels to our
user interface.
So we want to start by creating this right hand panel.
So we want a size box.
So we'll type in size on the top left hand side, grab a size box and get a size box at
the bottom here.
I will add it outside this vertical box actually, size box, and we'll call this size box, the
right panel, for example.
So we'll just call this right panel size box.
So we know exactly what that is.
We want a grid panel view.
So we want to get the grid and we want a grid panel view on this section here.
So we want to child the grid panel, make sure that's underneath the size box there, and
just compile and save.
And we'll get this grid size box and just bring it over into some better real estate
there.
For example, there, you can even anchor it to the right right hand side there instead
of the left, if you wanted to make sure it's right aligned.
And so in this panel, we want to add three buttons.
So we want an open and close button and a tab button.
So we will add the open button first.
So we'll go to button, add the button here, and that can go under the grid panel.
And then we'll call, we'll just keep, because we're adding so many components at the same
time, we'll just keep all our naming consistent.
So we want open, close, button, and then we will add another button as well.
And this one will be called tab 01 button.
And then we'll add some text to, oh, I changed the open, close button text in there.
So let's rename that open, close button and selecting this button here.
And we'll call this tab 01 button.
And then we want some text under this tab button.
So we'll add the text similar to how we did last time.
And we've got the text block there.
And this text will be the audio text box.
So we'll just say audio here.
And then we want another tab button.
So I'm just going to duplicate this by right clicking duplicate, and that'll bring the
button with it as well.
So this will be tab 02 button.
And then keep that renamed.
And then this one, instead of audio, will be radio.
If I can spell radio, there we go.
And then I'll just make sure in the audio text book, I've got audio.
So it says audio.
And then I will call this text radio.
There we go.
We'll compile and save and then start formatting everything now.
So to begin with, we want to sort out our grid panel here.
And we want to add the properties to the fill rule.
So let's add a column fill.
Let's add three indexes here.
And you want to input one, one, and leave index zero as zero.
And then on the row, we want zero.
And then we want a one on the one integer and zero there.
And then we will compile and save.
And then we just want to make sure our buttons are aligned correctly.
So the open close button will click the downward arrow there.
On audio, we will click that button there.
And then on our radio will go one, two.
And so we've got our button functionality as well.
So we can add spacing as well and padding where needed if you want to on the options.
We can do that by just typing padding and then answering some kind of numerical value.
If it's 10 or 20 or whatever that padding might be, maybe 20 looks good there.
We'll just give it its own spacing.
Something like that.
Again, as soon as we start getting down to the visual level, it's up to you how you want
to format things.
But that'll be our basic layout.
And then the last option that we want, the last palette option is a widget switcher.
So we just want to drag and drop the widget switcher down here and just remove that and
make sure the widget switcher is called widget switcher.
And we'll compile and save that.
And then we will drop down the slot and the grid slot.
And under the row variable, we want to change row to one and the column to one and the column
span to two.
There we go.
And then compile and save again.
And that's our basic right panel setup.
So we'll move into scripting the functionality next.
So into our graph, we will find some spare real estate and we want to select the tab
01 button here.
And as soon as you select that, you'll see an on clicked event.
So we'll just add the on clicked event and we will find the widget switcher, hold down
Ctrl and drag to get the variable and we'll type set active widget index.
And we'll hook that into there.
And then we'll also find tab 02 button on clicked.
And then the exact same thing.
So we'll copy and paste that.
So I've just Ctrl C, Ctrl V the function there, and we'll change this index to one.
And that'll set up some basic activity with the widget switcher on how to select each
one.
Next, we will go back into our designer.
And under our widget switcher, we will get a vertical, vertical, get a vertical box.
We've got that there.
And we will get a horizontal box as well.
Horizontal box.
And we're going to start building out a volume widget here.
So we will get the vertical box, this will be the audio tab.
So we want some kind of text input combo, which will be volume.
So text, vertical, we'll call this volume.
Let's just select the text box volume.
And we could even center this up.
I could even add some padding if you wanted.
I won't start getting deep into the visual style at the moment.
So we got our text box, text says volume, and then we want a spin, spin box as well
adding to the vertical box.
And that'll be this here.
So we want to make sure on this that there is some numerical value in there.
We also want to set some kind of properties as well.
So we want to make sure that the slider has the options set.
So we'll scroll down here to slider.
And the min property here is going to be zero.
So just make sure that that's at zero.
The max is going to be zero.
We could actually go to zero to 11 there actually.
And then always use Delta snap.
We can enable, we can make sure the Delta is at one there.
Slider exponent is also okay there.
And there should be, is the slider enabled?
Let's just check.
Yeah, so is enabled.
That's okay.
We've got the basic functionality in the slider set there.
And I might just add some padding to this just to give it a bit more space in there.
So again, just compile and save.
Next we will add another text box.
So add text below in this here.
Again we'll center it up.
We'll just make sure everything's aligned correctly.
And we'll call this text.
Let's find the text option.
And we'll call this balance.
And we could even just start naming these text blocks as well.
So we know exactly what each of the text blocks are, just in case we need to reference them
in blueprint.
That is purely just naming convention, so it's not going to affect any functionality.
So you can name them whatever you'd like.
And then we want a slider now for balance.
So we'll add a slider onto the vertical box.
And the slider is going to have these values of, so value is 0.5 here.
And the thumb image size is going to be 60.
Let's make sure we get the correct options here.
So we can type in thumb image.
And this will be the normal thumb image.
So from 8 and 14, we just want to change to 60 on both inputs there.
So 60 and 60.
And then if we cancel that out, the last thing we want is the thickness.
So again, I'll just type this property, the bar thickness.
I'll just change that to 1.
Oh, 10.
There we go.
That'll look better.
And then you can compile and save.
So we've got some basic UMG layouts for the volume and balance here.
Now let's switch to our horizontal box that we added before.
So we can either just select this and all of the other information will disappear just
because we've gone from the vertical box to the horizontal box.
So don't worry if anything disappears.
It's because we've got the horizontal box there.
Alternatively, just to show that the widget switcher is working as intended, you can actually
change the active widget index from 0.
If I can just select 0 to 1 and it'll go from 0 to 1, which is exactly what we did
in the graph here.
So it's just toggling between two different options, which is a really nice functionality.
So we've got our horizontal box.
And again, we want to create a couple of options here.
So we want two different text inputs.
We want saved and we want the station slider here.
So on the horizontal box, we will go to a text input and we'll drag the horizontal box
here and this one will be called saved in the text.
So we'll just select the text box there and we'll type saved.
So we've got that there.
And then we will make sure we have a named slot.
So named slots underneath here.
And that name slot can actually go underneath the text in this instance.
And we will, so to get the name slot underneath there, we'll need a vertical box.
So add the vertical box under the horizontal box, and then we'll add the text under the
vertical and the named under there.
And so that will get them to stack OK.
And then we want the combo box adding.
So combo box, which is the string version, and that will just go under the named slot
there.
So that'll be our basic vertical box functionality.
And so then we will add the exact same, but call this a station.
So we can maybe even right click, duplicate the vertical box here, and then we'll change
this text to station instead of saved.
So station will be there.
And we don't actually need the combo box this time.
So we can delete that one.
I'll rename this name slot to maybe let's call it station named slot.
And you don't need to rename your content.
It's more just to keep organized as this list ever expands.
It's good to keep things organized.
So I'll call this, this other one station named slot.
There we go.
So we can see exactly what we're doing.
And then on the second vertical, we'll call this vertical, we'll rename it, let's say
text input combo.
And this will be the station one.
And then this one will rename text input combo.
And this will be the saved one.
So this helps keep things a little bit more organized.
And then on the second text input combo, which is the station, we just now want to
add a slider.
So we will go to the top, we will add a slider, and we will add this to here.
And we can actually change this version of the slider.
If we type in orientation, we can actually change this to vertical, which will look much
better.
So the values for this one will be, let's see on the slider, we've got the value, let's
call this 80.
Let's say the min value is 80.
And the max value in this instance will be 110.
We've already changed the orientation.
Let's change the step size.
And we'll call this point one instead of point zero one.
We'll change the thumb size again.
And we will call this one, maybe 40 by 100.
And again, changing that bar thickness as we did last time as well.
We'll change this one to 10.
So that's our basic styling done.
And we now want to make sure this gets resized correctly.
So let's maybe move this down here.
And then maybe let's just try and fill this out here.
So that will look much better.
We could even change the horizontal.
So we can change all the padding, things like this.
So maybe let's try value of 20 again.
And then maybe on each individual padding as well, we just pad this out a little bit
more.
Again, we're working with a lot of different properties.
So you can kind of balance this to however you want it to look.
And then this slider, this slider, let's just check the value here.
That thumb, that thumb size doesn't feel right.
So let's just check the thumb.
So normal thumb image size.
Let's see, let's try 40 and 100.
There we go.
That's made it look much better.
So yeah, that value can then be set to 80 and we're okay to move on.
So compile and save and we'll move on to the next section.
So let's move into some visual scripting now.
So we'll go back to our graph.
And this time we want the station slider.
So the slider that we've got is our station slider, which again, we didn't rename.
So let's go in there and rename it so we can keep track of everything.
So this slider 260 is our station slider, but let's make sure that's named correctly
so we know exactly where it is.
We'll compile and save, jump back into the graph.
And now we've got the slider station here.
So we actually want the, you've got a few different options, but we actually want the
value changed option on the bottom here.
So we'll just click on value changed.
And then we just want to create a new custom event.
So just right click custom event and we'll call this update station text.
And we will actually then compile and save on the value changed.
And this will just keep things modular.
We will update the station text.
So we'll click up, enter there and whatever we named this custom event, that's what this
is calling.
So if we double click this, you'll see that we go to this section here, which is really
nice functionality.
And we can actually add a new pin into the value by, I used to be able to drag that.
I'm pretty sure, but anyway, we'll add a new input here and we'll call this just value.
There we go.
Change this to a float.
So now we've got a value value.
You'll see that this box is updated here and we can just drag and drop that in there.
So whatever value the slider feeds into this event, we'll get this output here.
This is what we were talking about when we were referring to working in a modular way.
So you can have this functionality over here, which feeds out to this functionality here.
So now we just want to update the text on the combo station based on whatever value
is being fed into here.
So we need to make sure we've got the correct text assigned.
And again, going back to good naming, we want to make sure that the text input combo there,
that station, we want to change that to get the text box here.
So the text is station.
Want to make sure that is a variable and we'll call this station text, compile and save.
So we're looking for a station text.
So we've got station text here.
We'll grab this and then we'll do a set text as we did before.
We've got a set text.
There we go.
We want to get this value and do a to text, which is in brackets, the flow.
So we have a few different properties down here that we can edit.
We'll just move this into position.
We'll drag this into here.
The use grouping, all these values are okay.
The min max digits can be two and three.
And the min max fractional digits are both one each.
There we go.
We'll just compile and save that.
Next we will edit the saved station.
So we'll go back into the designer and the combo box here, which is the saved.
We have this combo box that we can select.
And so we want to make sure that the default option, we'll just type in non here and set
non to the selected option.
And then content pattern, that should be okay as is.
We want to make sure that the down arrow is false.
So has down arrow is false.
And then item style, the text color is white.
So item style.
And we want to find the text color, make that white.
There we go.
And then the font, the size can be 20 in this instance.
And an outline can be two.
So let's see, outline size is two.
And you can also of course add a button padding if you want to.
And I've just compiled and saved this and noticed that the text isn't the correct color.
So let's just make sure we fix that before moving on.
So you can actually, I think maybe change the foreground color.
Yeah, let's just change that foreground color to a white and then non should be correct.
So you should end up with something like this.
If I go back down to the horizontal box, I'll actually maybe just try and collapse some of this here
so we can see a little bit better.
But that should be overall what we're looking at for that section.
Next, we want to create a list of saved stations.
So we'll go back into our graph here and we'll create a new variable, which is a saved station list.
So let's say saved station list and the variable type will be a string to float.
Let's just add a string.
Let's change that to an array, a map.
And then so yeah, string and then to map.
And then we want the actual flow here.
There we go.
And then we can compile and save that.
And as we're adding variables, sometimes it's easier to just separate these out into maybe call it the setting config,
the category config or something like this.
And then if you do the display text and change that to config,
it'll create its own group of variables that you edit.
So sometimes if you've got a whole list of variables here, it can just be a little bit easier to keep everything organized there.
So just worth keeping in mind.
The pre-construct, we'll just delete this now because this was just a test.
So I won't do that.
I'll compile and save.
And then now we want to get this saved station list.
And then we want to get the keys from this.
So we'll type keys.
We'll add this to the execution line.
There we go.
And then we'll for each from this array.
So let's for each loop through this series of keys here.
So we'll just loop through the whole station list and to try and find a certain variable.
So from the array, we'll do add option.
Well, from the actual station list, sorry, which is the combo box that we added before.
So let's just make sure we have combo.
So we've called that combo box string.
So let's rename that combo.
Again, this is why naming convention is good.
So combo box save station.
Let's go back to our graph now.
Let's go back into here.
Drag this out, holding down control.
And then we'll add the option from here.
Add option array element into there.
So that's our pre-construct.
So we can compile and save.
And then we want on the combo saved stations.
We actually want to change this property.
So let's start commenting out our code so we know exactly what we're doing.
So you can actually select a few boxes and you can just say like pre-construct and press
C on the keyboard.
Add that comment box and you can actually change the color if you want.
If you're looking at any kind of execution wiring or anything like this, you can go to
town on the font size, all this kind of stuff.
So I just I'm going to keep things organized.
Pressing C on my keyboard again.
Widget switcher is there.
Slider station.
This is purely for organization.
So it's completely up to you if you decide to do this.
But it just helps see things at a higher level, exactly what's going on,
especially when you've got a lot of blueprint being coded.
So I'm just going to compile and save that.
So from this combo box saved stations now, we will see the on selection changed here.
So let's add this as a property here and we'll go get the saved station list from here.
And we will drag off and type find.
The selected item we will add into here.
We will look for a specific value and then the slider station text, which is in the designer.
So the slider station text, which is this, we'll go back into our graph.
So that's the station text that we've got selected.
Now we want to set a value here.
Set.
That's not the text that we want, is it?
It's the actual slider.
So let's grab the slider.
There we go.
Slider.
Station.
Let's grab the slider.
That's what we want to do.
Set value and drag that into there.
And then the value can get passed out into there.
And now, now we want to update the station text.
So go back to our designer, we'll get our station text, go back into our graph.
And then we will check that out there.
And actually we have a update station text function already created.
So let's just call that update station text because now we're reusing functionality.
So we'll type update station text and you'll see that option there.
And you just want to make sure whatever you called this event that we created before,
you can just call that here and we can just drag out from the find and add that in there.
If you want to clean things up, you can double click and create
re-root nodes on the actual line.
And I can hold down alt on my keyboard and drag that in there.
If you just want to make things a little bit cleaner, I'm just going to compile and save
and we can move on to the next section.
And then lastly, it'd be useful to show you some animation functionality if you want to add this
for yourself.
So we can actually go back into the designer and you'll see I've got an animation window
open at the bottom here.
If you don't have that open, you can just go to window, animations,
and this animation box will appear for you.
And I'll just select the right panel size box and we will add an animation
and we will just call this a close open panel.
And if we select that now, we can add a track.
So we want to make sure we have the right panel size box here.
We will go to track, add rights panel size box.
And we can now add a transform.
So we'll go to track and we will add a transform and we can actually drop down this transform here.
And we don't actually care about any of the other properties here.
We mostly care about the translation.
So I'm going to right click and delete the rotation.
I'm going to delete the scale.
I'm going to delete the shear.
I just care about the translation.
I actually only really care about the translation in X because I want to move from left to right.
So I'm going to drag out maybe however many seconds you want the animation to go over.
I'm just going to drag to maybe three seconds.
I'm going to add an X key there and then I'm going to go back over to here
and I want to change this translation maybe to maybe to 843.
For example, I'm just scrolling across here.
And now when I press play, you'll see that this slides into view over three seconds.
So again, this is a very rudimentary kind of animation.
I'm sure you could create something much nicer with giving a bit more time.
And I just want to show you some basic animation inside of UMG if you wanted to add that.
So to actually add that functionality.
So we've got the animation here, but it's not actually part of the project.
So if we want to add that into the project, we can go back into our graph
and we can find some empty space and the open close button that we created at the very start.
We can just go to the on clicks of the open close button
and we can get the close open animation.
So we can make sure that we find the animation.
Let's just make sure it's a variable.
So let me just go to the graph, open, close panel.
There we go.
Just make sure it's called that.
So close open panel.
So I'll just right click close open panel and then I can play that animation.
So actually I want to play the animation forward in this instance.
So play animation forward.
I'll just delete that.
And there we go.
And then we can actually just play that animation in reverse as well.
Now, every time we click this button, we want it to do the opposite of what it just did.
So I can drag out from the execution pin.
I can flip flop here, add that flip flop in there, and actually just drag that into that.
So every time I click the button, it'll play the animation.
And every time I click it again, it'll reverse that animation.
So keep flip flop in between, play in reverse, play in reverse.
And therefore that will add the desired functionality that we want.
So now let's make sure this all works in situ.
So I'm going to go back to my designer.
I'm going to find this first key.
I'll make sure that the first key is this little button here
because that's going to open the actual animation.
So we'll see that that will open on the side.
I can delete this text for now.
That was just example.
So we'll compile and save.
So this is everything that we've seen so far.
Because we've got our controller, we're adding the UMG to the screen.
So that's already added.
So let's go back into our map.
Let's just make sure everything is saved before we try this out.
We'll go to full screen hitting F11.
I'm going to press Alt and P on my keyboard.
Now it's out by default, but let's just check that this is working.
So we can actually change that first key.
But you'll see that this opens and closes, reversing and opening.
So that's really nice functionality.
And we have the different audio and radio stations
and we can update these based on those properties.
So hopefully that gives you a good overview of the UMG
and different functionalities we can add inside of our interfaces.
If we had our test map open, then we'd be able to see our car
in the background and have all that, the functionality
required for that car configurator opening and closing.
So hopefully you found that useful and we'll jump into the closing comments.